-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
You're here. You're watching.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Let's get to some news.
Well, guys, today
President Biden announced
that the U.S. is banning imports
of Russian vodka, diamonds,
and seafood.
Yeah.
In related news,
the next season
of "The Bachelor"
is delayed until further notice.
[ Laughter and applause ]
But don't worry, there's still
a guy in Times Square
selling all that stuff
on a blanket.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"That looks good."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, the White House
just held a Zoom call
with 30 of the biggest
TikTok stars
to brief them
on the war in Ukraine.
[ Laughter ]
Then, later in the day,
Biden discussed mind-blowing
life hacks with the Pentagon.
[ Laughter ]
The meeting ended
after the TikTok stars
talked Biden
into inhaling tanning spray.
[ Laughter ]
Jeesh!
Speaking --
Speaking of TikTok,
I read that sales
at Barnes & Noble
are skyrocketing
because so many
TikTokers have been posting
about buying books at the store.
[ Laughter ]
Right now, RadioShack is like,
"For the love of God, do that
with old electronics,
old electronics!
Get into old --
Batteries, something!"
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
Barnes & Noble is like,
"Oh, man, we're this close
to no longer being considered
a public restroom.
We're this close.
Almost there."
[ Laughter and applause ]
But this is exciting --
this weekend is
Selection Sunday,
which means March Madness is
almost here, yeah!
[ Cheering and applause ]
That's right,
it's that time of year
when people spend hours
on their brackets
and then do their taxes
in five minutes.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, this Sunday is also
Daylight Savings Time.
[ Cheering ]
Yep, that's right,
we'll lose an hour.
And if you watched
"The Masked Singer"
on Wednesday,
that means you lost two hours.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Get this --
according to a new survey,
Americans who live
in the Northeast
are the worst snorers
in the country.
[ Laughter ]
Which I guess explains
the new Mucinex commercial
airing in Boston. Watch this.
-I bet you snore like an [bleep]
-Yeah, thanks to you.
I got loogies at nighttime
and it's hardcore
wicked unpleasant.
[ Laughter ]
-You blow chunks outta tea?
-I sers wheeze
when I'm at Dunky's.
-You sound like a chowderhead.
-I'm not going to argue
with a frickin' sack of puke.
-Watch this Green Monster
bang a U-ey.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Can we get Plymouth Rock
out of the frickin' aisle?
-He's a townie.
-If you snore
like a little bitch,
get Mucinex Fast Night Time,
you frickin' jerk.
Go, Sox!
-Unbelievable.
They're airing that.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Wow!
-They're airing it in Boston.
I saw that.
-In Boston.
Airs in Boston.
-I have a Boston feed
in my office.
[ Voices overlapping ]
Exactly.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, I saw, guys,
for the first time ever,
the Tin Man's oil can
from "The Wizard of Oz"
is going up for auction.
[ Audience oohs ]
The bidding starts at $200,000.
But only because it has
a little oil left in it.
[ Cheering and applause ]
And, finally,
the U.S. Border agents
arrested a man in California
after they found 52 reptiles
hidden under his clothes.
[ Ews and ohs ]
Authorities were suspicious when
a tongue shot out of his fly
and ate a mouse.
[ Laughter and applause ]
We have a great show.